[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه التاسعه
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
اسوء عاصفه ثلجيه بتاريخ امريكا تقتل 25
شخصا في بافلو وحدها وتحاصر مئات الالاف
منظمه دوليه خامسه تعلق عملها بافغانستان
بعد تمسك طالبان بقرار حضر النساء من
العمل
سفاره السعوديه في باكستان تدعو مواطنيها
لتوخي الحذر بعد رفع حاله التاهب في اسلام
اباد
[موسيقى]
وفي سوريا ثمانيه قتلى بهجوم لداعش على
سجن بالرقه والتحالف يكثف عمليته ضد
التنظيم
[موسيقى]
ايام اخرى عصيبه يعيشها ملايين الامريكيين
طبعا مع استمرار العاصفه الثلجيه القاسيه
التي خلفت خسائر كبيره في الارواح عاصفه
شتويه خلفت 46 على الاقل في انحاء البلاد
وبينما لا يزال السكان في غرب نيويورك
محاصرين تحت اقدام من الثلوج لم تعد اجهزه
الطوارئ قادره على التعامل مع الظروف
الصعبه الناجمه عن الصقيع الناجم عن
العاصفه الثلجيه وايضا انخفاض درجات
الحراره
[موسيقى]
اطفال
هناك
المزيد من الارقام الخاصه
بالاضافه الى هذه التصريحات اكد مفاوض على
اشغال العامه في مدينه بافلوبي نيويورك
اكد بان التركيز الان يتجه نحو الحفاظ على
سلامه الارواح بعدما كان ينصب على تامين
المتاجر طبعا للوصول الى الغذاء تصريحات
تشير الى ان هذه العاصفه هي الاكثر تدميرا
في تاريخ بافلوط طويل حيث ادى تساقط
الثلوج الى جعل الطرق غير سالكه طبعا مع
انعدام الرؤيا ارتفع عدد الوفيات المؤكده
والمرتبطه بالعواصف الثلجيه في تلك
المنطقه الى 25 حاله وفاه
نتحدث عن الحياه والامان وكيفيه الوصول
الى شخص عالق كما تعلمون الطعام من عناصر
الحياه والامان لكن الان ينصب تركيزنا على
الحياه والسلامه فقط
وفقه شبكه سي ان ان العاصفه الشتويه تسببت
في دفن اجزاء من غرب نيويورك بما يصل الى
43 بوصه من الثلوج مما ترك المركبات عالقه
وادى الى انقطاع التيار الكهربائي وذلك
للالاف وفي احدى مقاطعات ولايه نيويورك
ابلغ المسؤولون عن ثلاثه عشره حاله وفاه
اضافيه طبعا بسبب العاصفه الثلجيه
الكارثيه واشنطن بوست من جهتها اكد بان
العاصفه الثلجيه تسببت في تجمد محطات
الكهرباء الفرعيه وايضا اغلاق بعض الطرقات
البلاد الاكثر انشغالا طبعا فتره اعياد
الميلاد الصحيفه اشارت الى ان اكثر من 10
ملايين شخص كانوا تحت انذارات التجميد
وذلك في جميع الب بما في ذلك سكان
اورلاندو ومونت مايكرو وبيراميدز
[موسيقى]
المزيد معنا من فرجينيا حسين الطوب مراسل
العربيه اهلا بك حسين يعني يبدو الجو اقل
ضررا اذا ما صحه تعبير من المناطق اخرى
خبرنا عن مشاهداتك واخر المعلومات
والتطورات
تحيه لك يا ميسونه بالفعل نحن هنا في
منطقه الساحل الشرقي جنوب جنوب
فيرجينيا الاردن فرجينيا الاوضاع افضل
بكثير من منطقه غربه ولايه
نيويورك تحديدا همم بافلو وما جاورها التي
نالت نصيب الاسد من اداء الانفجار القطبي
تحديدا في مقاطعه هناك اكثر من 25 خط
يره مرشح للزياده في تلك المنطقه في غرب
ولايه نيويورك همم هذه المنطقه همم ميسون
المفارقه انها مواجهه بادوات ومعدات
لمواجهه العواصف الثلجيه ولكن هذه العاصفه
كما وصفها بعض السكان في تلك المنطقه هي
حرب مع همم
حكم المنطقه قال بان همم هذا هذه العاصفه
اشد حتى من العاصفه التي ضربت المنطقه عام
1977 رغم ان تلك العاصفه كانت مدتها اطول
ولكن قوه هذه العاصفه قوه هذه الرياح وعدد
القتل حتى الان تجاوز ما حدث عام 1977
تاثير العاصفه هذا الانفجار القطبي كما
يوصف وصالح حتى الولايات الجنوبيه التي
توصل بالدافع في امريكا ولايه فلوريدا ولا
تعيش عدد من سكانها تحت همم الانذارات
البرد والصقيع همم ايضا هذه العاصفه
تتسببت بحدوث اعطال كثيره في شبكات
الكهرباء ومول الطاقه بسبب سوء المواطنين
بشكل طبيعي الى وسائل التدفئه محمد ضغطا
كبيرا على هذه الشركات الشبكات الشبكات
الكهربائيه ما دفع السلطات ايضا الى الطلب
من المواطنين بترشيد استخدامهم للادوات
التثبيعه
فيما يتعلق بالاثار هذه هل كانت متوقعه
وهل تعتبر طبيعيه في ظل همم هذا الانفجار
العاصي كما ذكرت ام انه لا هناك كان من
اليوم من الممكن ان يكون بعض التجهيزات
والتحضيرات لها
ميسون يعني عندما نتحدث عن مدينه بافلو
بافلو معروفه بانها هي على حدود الكنديه
هذه المنطقه معروفه انها تصاب دائما
بعواصف وبثل كثيفه ولكن مع ذلك رغم انها
مجهزه لم تستطع الصمود امام هذه العاصفه
ما يدل على ان هذه العاصفه تخطت كل
التوقعات يعني هناك من يتحدث عنها عاصفه
الجيل هي تحدث في الجيل مره واحده هناك
كما يقول يصفها بعاصفه القرن لم يكن من
المتوقع ان تكون بهذه الشده ولكن يا جماعه
لا ننسى ان هناك تحضيرات من قبل العلماء
لان هناك تغير مناخي كبير على الصعيد
الكره الارضيه كلها هذا ما قد يفسره البعض
او يفسر عن بعض قوه هذه العاصفه انها
نتيجه لهذا التغير المناخي السلطات
الامريكيه يعني لم تدخل جهدا وهي تحضر
وتجهز ولكن كما قال ذكرنا هناك من يصف ما
يحدث الان خاصه في الولايات الشماليه
بانها حرب مع ال- ال- الطبيعه الام حتى
قوات الحرس الوطني التي ااا استعان بها او
استعان بها السلطات الامريكيه واجهت مشاكل
في الوصول الى المواطنين رغم انهم مدربون
على ذلك العديد من الوفيات ميسون اما
كانوا عالقين في سياراتهم او هناك من من
كان له مواجهه مضاعفات صحيه ولكن الفرق
على الاغاثه لم تستطع عن الوصول الى الرغم
كل الامكانيات الجباره التي تملكها
الحكومه الامريكيه وخاصه في تلك المنطقه
بسبب تساقط الثلوج بسبب انقطاع الطرق
والتي حتى الان السلطات الامريكيه تحذر
المواطنين من الخروج في هذه الطرق ومن
التوجه الى تلك المنطقه بسبب الانطلاقات
همم الحادثه بسبب الجديد وبسبب انعدام
الرؤيه هل ستستمر الى متى ما هي التوقعات
وهل في تصاعد اكثر او لا
بالنسبه للمناطق الشماليه وتحديدا في
بافلو من المتوقع ان يبدا الثلج الان وحتى
غدا ولكن مع مرور الايام خلال الاسبوع
القادم من المطلقه ان يتحسن الجو هنا في
في فرجينيا شمال فرجينيا وفي الساحل
الشرقي بدات درجات الحراره ترتفع قليلا
اليوم صباحا كنا نشعر بده درجه الحراره
تحت الصفر الان نحن صفر درجه حراره مئويه
ولكن طبعا الشعور يكون امرا منها من
المتوقع تتحسن ما على الايام القادمه او
حتى عطله نهايه الاسبوع بان تصل الى ما
كانت على سابقا على درجات الحراره
الطبيعيه في هذا الموسم البارد هو في
الحقيقه ولكن ليس بهذه الدرجه التي شعرنا
بها مؤخرا في الايام الثلاثه والاربعه
الماضي
شكرا جزيلا لك
ومن امريكا الشماليه الى شرق اسيا تسببت
الثلوج الكثيفه في مناطق شاسعه من اليابان
بمقتل 17 شخصا واصابه اكثر من 90 اخرين
وايضا انقطاع الكهرباء عن مئات المنازل
وفقا لما ذكره مسؤوله اداره الكوارث
اليابانيه نتابعه
[موسيقى]
تستمر وتداعيات انتهاكات حركه طالبان بحق
النساء اذا اعلنت منظمه بريطانيه تعليق
عملها في افغانستان لتكون بذلك خامس منظمه
انسانيه هذه الخطوه في البلاد فيما حتى
بيان للامم المتحده حكومه طالبان على
الغاء قرار حظر عملي موظفات المنظمات غير
الحكوميه البعث اضافت ان ملايين الافغان
بحاجه الى المساعده الانسانيه الا ان
الحركه لم ترد على طلب الاممي حتى هذه
اللحظات
في افغانستان تعليم النساء و عملهن ممنوع
بقوه قانون طالبان خطوه جرت على الحركه
انتقادات دوليه واسعه حتى من حكومات تمارس
انواع القمع والتسلط على النساء النظام
الايراني الجهود الدوليه والمطالب بالغاء
القرار متواصله
الامم المتحده الى افغانستان حتى القائمه
باعمال وزير الاقتصاد في حكومه طالبان على
الغاء خطوه حظر عمل موظفه منظمه غير
الحكوميه بعثه الامم المتحده للمساعده في
افغانستان قالت في بيان ان ملايين الافغان
بحاجه الى المساعده الانسانيه ومن الضروري
تذليل العقبه الموجوده وزاره الاقتصاد في
حكومه طالبان سبق ان حدثت جميع المنظمات
غير الحكوميه المحليه منها والاجنبيه بمنع
موظفيها من العمل حتى اشعار اخر الاوامر
لا تنطبق بشكل مباشر على الامم المتحده
لكن المنظمات غير الحكوميه التي يشملها
القرار تتولى تنفيذ الكثير من برامج الامم
المتحده ما يهدد بازمه اخرى ستواجه النساء
والاسره الافغانيه لتضاف الى كل الازمات
التي يعاني منها الشعب الافغاني
بلال الوجديني العربيه
والناشطه الافغانيه زينب حكيمي في تصريحا
للعربيه قالت ان الضغوطات والاذنات
الدوليه لقرار طالبان منع الفتيات من
التعليم سيكون لها تاثير داعيه الى ضروره
اقتران هذه الاذنات بالضغوط المدنيه من
داخل افغانستان تحدث عن المظاهرات
استقالات الاساتذه من الجامعات كمثال
هذه الضغوط هذه يعني طبعا لها تاثير يعني
نحن همم
ننتظر تاثير هذه الاذنات ولهذه الضغوط
ولكن اذا يجتمع معها كذلك ضغوط مدنيه من
داخل الافغانستان والنصف الشعب الافغاني
واا خاصه مثلا نحن همم راينا بان الاساتذه
الاساتذه في الجامعات استقالوا يعني وكل
هذه يعني المظاهرات الاعتراضات المدنيه
كلها هذه الضغوط طبعا سيكون لها تاثير
تنافس واتهامات بمن يقمع النساء اكثر من
الاخر النظام الايراني ام حركه طالبان هذا
ما ظهر واضحا من تبادل لاتهامات بين
الجانبين مؤخرا النظام الايراني ندد
بقرارات طالبان بعد منع النساء من الدراسه
في الجامعات الافغانيه والعمل ايضا تمديد
فسره البعض على انه اشاره الى ان طهران
تتعامل مع النساء بشكل اكثر لطفا من طالبا
طبعا هذه التصريحات تاتي في وقت يواجه فيه
النظام الايراني موجه تحتجاجات كبيره
اساسها المراه التي ترفض سياسه طهران
تجاهها حريه وحقوق المراه في البلاد وزاره
خارجيه حركه طالبان لم تتاخر في الرد على
الانتقادات الايرانيه ودعت في تغريده
طهران لاقناع النساء المحتجات اولا اولا
هناك وعدم محاوله لفت النظر عما يحدث في
بلادهم اي في ايران
[موسيقى]
والمزيد معنا من قبل ذكيه
اهلا بك يا سيده ذكيه اسمحي لي ان ابدا
بهذه الاتهامات المتبادله ما بين
افغانستان
وطهران او المشاده الكلاميه عبر تويتر
اه كونان
مبارك
كونان
[موسيقى]
توقف هنا لانه يبدو ان هناك مشكله في
الصوت وترجمه واعود اليك بعد قليل لنكمل
هذا الحديث مع ترجمه واضحه اكثر
[موسيقى]
طلبت السفاره السعوديه في باكستان رعاياها
بتوخي الحذر بعد رفع السلطات حاله التاهب
الامني في العاصمه اسلام اباد لاعلى
مستوياتها حتى السفاره السعوديه مواطنيها
في باكستان عبر حسابها على تويتر باخذ
الحيطه والحذر وعدم الخروج الا للضروره
وكذلك التواصل مع السفاره والقنصليه
العامه في كراتشي في حاله الضروره
طبعا التحضير السعودي ياتي بعد يومين على
تحضيرات للصفارتين الامريكيه والبريطانيه
من هجوم المحتمل على فندق كبير بالعاصمه
خلال فتره العطولات كانت طالبان باكستان
اعلنت اخيرا عن استئناف العمليات
الارهابيه
التاسعه مستمره وفيها ولكن بعد قليل
[موسيقى]
تحسبا لهجوم من الشمال الجيش الاوكرانيه
يتدرب قرب الحدود البيلاروسيا
[موسيقى]
واهلا بكم مجددا الى التاسعه مشاهدينا
وهذه عوده الى ملف افغانستان والتطورات
هناك ما يتعلق بقرار طالبان منع المراه من
الذهاب الى العمل او حتى الطالبات الى
المدرسه وكنت اتحدث من كابول كانت معي
ذكيه نهضه الناشطه النسويه وهي تنضم مجددا
الي الان واا كنت قد سالتك فيما يتعلق
بالاتهامات المتبادله تمديد طهران بما
تقوم به همم افغانستان فيما يتعلق بالمراه
وحقوق المراه اي من الدولتين الطف مع
المراه برايك
لسه
وانا افغانستان
ماسنجر
او نشرات اخرى العوده اليك ولكن هناك
مشكله في الصوت من المصدر شكرا جزيلا لك
اظهرت مقاطع فيديو نشرتها القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه جنود اوكرانيين يتدربون لمنع
اي هجوم محتمل من القوات التكتيكيه
المحموله جوا على منشاتها الحيويه قال
الجيش الاوكراني ان مجموعات من قوته
والحرس الوطني تجري تدريبات عسكريه في
مكان يقع بالقرب من الحدود مع بلروسيا
متابعه
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا دعونا نتحدث عن قاعده او حديقه
الاتحاد الروسي طبعا هي اهم منشئه عسكريه
في العمق الروسي حيث يرتكز فيها اسطول
كبير من القاذفات الاستراتيجيه تعتمد
عليها موسكو وبدرجه كبيره في عملياتها
الدفاعيه وايضا العسكريه
قاعده جويه عسكريه استراتيجيه تقع على بعد
14 كلم
وهي مدينه روسيه تبعد عن موسكو بحواله 858
كلم القاعده تعتبر الركيزه الاساسيه للجيش
الروسي مختلف العمليات الجويه التي يقوم
بها وخصوصا طبعا في الفتره الاخيره فمن
خلال هذه القاعده تنفذ روسيا كل عمليات
قادفات القنابل الرئيسيه وهي ايضا موقع
التشغيل الوحيد للجيش الروسي للقادفات
الاستراتيجيه
160 تضم القاعده مدرجا 3,500 متر وحوالي
10 اغطيه كبيره بحيث تتمركز بها قاذفات
القنابل الاستراتيجيه للطيران بعيد المدى
قدفات تجعل من الصعب استهدافها باعمال
تقريبيه او تنفيذ ضربات سريعه عليها ومن
هذه القاعده تحديدا يمكن تنفيذ العديد من
الهجمات الصاروخيه على الاراضي الاخرانيه
بقادفات تدخل المجال الجوي لبحر قزوين
ليصل بعدها الى عمق الهدف طبعا المدروس
جديد بالذكر ان هذه القاعده تضم اكثر من
20 قادفت قنابل بما في ذلك تو 160
و95 ذات القدره النوويه يعد استهداف
القاعده من طرف الجيش الاوكراني مهمه صعبه
للغايه خاصه ان هذه القاعده ومنذ بدايه
العمليات العسكريه الروسيه تخضع لحراسه
عاليه المستوى
[موسيقى]
كشفت مجله
وجود نقطه ضعف في نظام باتريات الامريكي
المقدم لاوكرانيا المجله اكدت بان استخدام
انظمه باتريوت لمواجهه الطائرات بدون طيار
باعداد كبيره سيسمح باختراق انظمه الدفاع
الجوي الاوكراني وفي التفاصيل بحسب هذه
المجله يمكن للطائرات الروسيه ان تستنتج
بسرعه صواريخ باتريوت المضاده للطائرات
وبالتالي اختراق دفاعاتها اما كما ان
تدمير باتريوت يمكن ان يكون ناجحا لسبب
رئيسي وهو انها تحريكها لتجنب الضربات ليس
بالامر السهل وفق عسكريين المجله تشير الى
ان تشغيل بطاريه واحده يتطلب جهود ثلاثه
اشخاص في حين ان نقلها يتطلب وجهود حوالي
90 شخص
[موسيقى]
تعيش مدينه تم موسكو وايضا كيف هذا العام
اجواء اعياد الميلاد وراس السنه ضمن ظروف
خاصه تبعا لوضع النزاع بين البلدين واقع
الحرب القى بظلاله على اجواء الاحتفالات
وعلى زينه المدن بالرغم من المفارقه
الكبيره التي تعكس الظروف المعيشيه
للشعبين الروسي والاكرانيا مراسيلينا عبد
الجواد الرشد وحذيفه عادل ينقلان لنا واقع
الاعياد والاحتفالات في موسكو وكياف
هكذا يبدو مركزه مدينه موسكو مستعدا
للاحتفال بعدي الميلادي وراس السنه في وقت
تدخل فيه عمليه البلاد العسكريه الخاصه في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه شهرها العاشر انه
قال حربي محزن للغايه او للاسف الحرب شيئا
واقع ومتكرر في الحياه التاريخ يعيد نفسه
ولا يمكن للاسف تغييره هذا
اما العاصمه الاوكرانيه فها هي شجره
الميلاد في ساحه القديسه الصوفيه تقف
مزينه تتركز على ضوء خافت من مولد يعمل
بالوقود وفترات محدوده ولاول مره بالوان
العلم الاوكراني وفي مكان نجمه الميلاد
رمز الدوله الاوكرانيه وعلى الرغم من غياب
خيام الحلوى والمشروبات الساخنه
والاحتفالات وباحات التزلجين الا ان بهجه
الاعياد حاضره رغما عنه في الحرب
الحلوه والمشروبات الساخنه لكن على اي حال
يجب ان نحافظ على روحي اعياد الميلاد لان
شبابنا المقاتلين في الجبهات يريدون ان
يواصل الناس حياتهم
في موسكو المكان والزمالك مفارقه كبيره
الزينه والاضواء تملان كل ارجاء المدينه
لاعاده البهجه والفرح للمواطن الروسي في
ظل الاوضاع الراهنه خاصه ان الشريط
الحدوديه للبلاد يعيش حاله توتر وسقوط
عشرات الصواريخ يوميا
بالسلام وخاصه اخرى
لكل روسي اقرباء في اوكرانيا ونحن شعب
واحد وهذه حقيقه
للاستسلام تبحث عن ما يمكن ان يطفي روحها
اعياد الميلاد في المدينه فكانت الحاجه ام
الاختراع لذا ابتكرت محطه قطاراته هذه
الفكره تمام
الطاقه ده دراجه رياضيه تحول الطاقه
الحركيه الى كهرباء لتضيء شجره الميلاديه
التي تزين صاله الركاب
انا ارى في ضوء هذه الشجره بلادنا الحره
المستقله
لاجتماع الاسره حتى ان البعض يطلق عليها
تسميتها العيد العائلي عدد من الشباب
يحتفل بغصه في الحلق هذه السنه بعيدا عن
جو العائله الى هرب من التعبئه والعديد من
العائلات الروسيه تستقبل عمها الجديد خارج
ديارهم التي لا طالما زقزقت فيها شمعه راس
السنه الجديده ورقص على انغامي تمنياتي
بالحبي والسلام بعدين كانت شوارعها سابقا
ترقص وتغني بزينه العيد ويختلط ليلها
بنارها بمشهد الرائعه هذه هي كيف تقابل
اعياد الميلاد والاسر والاكرانيه في حاله
من الشتات النساء والاطفال غادروا بلادهم
والرجال منتصرون على الجبهات والباقوله
يواجهون اوضاع الانسانيه كارثه ولسان
حالهم يقول باي حال عدت يا عيد
[موسيقى]
كشف تقرير لصحيفه جورنال تصاعد العمليات
العسكريه ضد داعش في سوريا تحديدا في
الجزء الشمالي منها تقرير اضعف ان القوات
الامريكيه نفذت خلال شهر ديسمبر ما لا يقل
عن عشره عمليات وغارات في سوريا ضد مواقع
للتنظيم وتنقل الصحيفه عن متحدث باسم
القوات الامريكيه ان العمليات المذكوره
ادت الى اعتقالي سته من عناصر داعش
مسؤولون عسكريون اضعفوا ان المداهمات تتم
عاده في الليل باستخدام مروحيات لقوات
العمليات الخاصه الجيش الامريكي كشف ايضا
ان تلك المداهمات الذات الى مقتلي مسؤول
اقليمي كبير في تنظيم داعش ودعاء الزبيدي
كما اكد مسؤولون عسكريون تنفيذ ثمانيه
غارات اخرى من بينها سبعا في وقت سابق من
هذا الشهر وواحده اخرى في اوائل اكتوبر
ادت الى مقتل او اعتقال عناصر اخرين من
داعش اللافت في هذا التقرير ان احدى
العمليات البريه ضد داعش في سوريا استمرت
ثلاث ساعات باعت ذلك في وقتنا ارتفع في
عدد لا هجوم داعش على مقر امني للقوات
الكرديه في الرقه الى ثمانيه مقاتله
[موسيقى]
المزيد ينضم الينا من الرقه العميد علي
الحسن الاداره العامه لقوى الامن الداخلي
شمال وشرق سوريا اهلا بك عميد علي اسمح لي
انا ابدا ببعض المعلومات من عندك عمليه
اليوم 11
تفاصيل اكثر لديك
مساء الخير لك ولجميع المشاهدين الاكارم
سنه خلايا داعش الارهابيه اليوم
صباحا هجوما على احد المراكز لقوه الامن
الداخلي في مدينه الرقه والذي يجاور سجن
لاعتقال مقاتليه داعش وكان الهدف هو
السيطره على هذا المركز الا ان تصدي
قواتنا
هذا الهجوم ببطوله وبساله افشلت المخطط
الارهابي بالدخول الى المركز وبالاصول الى
ايضا مركز السجن تم قتل احد العناصر
المهاجمه وايضا تم اعتقال احدهم يلبس حزام
ناسف
وفيما فر ال بقيه ال- ال- الخليه الى
الاحياء المجاوره وبدات بعدها عمليه تمشيط
واسعه همم وما زالت مستمره عمليه التمشيط
للقبض على همم
همم العناصر المتواريه عن الانظار ضمن
الاحياء السكنيه
من المقاتلين بمعنى اخر سبعه من جانبكم قد
سقطوا
عن قتيل من الخلايا
المهاجمه واستشهاد الست عناصر
اربعه من قوى الامن الداخلي واثنان من
مقاتلين قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه طبيعه
الاسلحه اللي كانت مستخدمه بعيدا عن عمليه
الحزام الناسف
طبعا استخدام الاسلحه الفرديه الاسلحه
كلاشنكوف
وطبعا همم هذه العناصر والقنابل ايضا
اليدويه بالاضافه ان هذه العناصر همم
عندما حاولوا الدخول الى مركز قوى الامن
الداخلي همم
العناصر المتواجده لدينا على الباب
الرئيسي وحدث الاشتباك بين عناصرنا وبيننا
هؤلاء الارهابيين من الخلايا النائمه همم
بالحقيقه استطاعت همم عناصرنا احباط هذا
الهجوم وافشال المخطط الكبير الذي كان
يخطئ همم
يستهدفون يعني السجن في عناصر من داعش
ويقال بانها من الاكثر ارهابا اذا ما صح
التعبير
طبعا قلنا بانهم يستهدفون الوصول الى
السجن معتقلين داعش فيما لو وصلوا الى
السجن ستكون هناك فوضى همم كبيره جدا
محاوله لتهريب هؤلاء العناصر من السجن
وبالتالي همم محاوله احداث خرق امني كما
حاولوا بسجن الصناعه في الحسكه سابقا
وايضا تم ارسالهم ولكن همم الان همم بعد
هذه المحاوله همم واثناء همم عمليه
التمشيه تم القاء القبض على اثنين ايضا
اخرين من هؤلاء الخلايا وما زالت هذه
الحمله مستمره حمله تمشيط واسعه كبيره جدا
في مدينه الرقه
في عمليه التنشيط هذا
دوري
القوات سوريا الديمقراطيه ومن قبل قوى
الامن الداخلي وطبعا تم اعلان حظر كلي في
التجوال في المدينه من اجل ايضا متابعه
عمليه التنشيط بشكل كامل
المفترض بانها تتمركز في الرقه تحديدا
جديده
بدايه طبعا نحن سابقا قلناها
كلما تزداد تهديدات التركيه لمناطقنا كلما
ازداد نشاط الخلايا الارهابيه كل من شغلنا
بالتصدي لمحاولات الدوله التركيه وايضا ال
ال المقاتلين الذين ينظرون تحت اا
دعم الاحتلال التركي بالهجوم على مناطقنا
استهداف مناطقنا بالطيران الحربي والطيران
المسير المستمر ادى الى محاوله الاستفاده
من انشغال قواتنا بهذه
الاوضاع وتهديدات المستمره على مناطقنا
قلناها ونكررها دوما ان داعمي داعش
يستفيدون من من ماذا من احداث هذا الفراغ
الامني وايضا احداث خلال ضمن المنطقه من
اجل تلويف
همم سمعه قواتنا وايضا احداث خلل لزعزعه
ثقه الاهالينا ولكن من خلال الاسلحه ومن
خلال العمليه هذه الهجوم والمعلومات
الاخرى التي وردت في الصحيفه ذكرناها قبل
قليل يبدو ان هناك من يدعمهم من يحركم من
يعطيهم الاسلحه
سابقا اااه
اعلنا وايضا من خلال الصفحاتنا على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي التحقيقات مع ناصر
الارهابيه التابعه للاعش همم تثبت بان همم
اغلبهم مرتبطين
بداعمين همم من المناطق الخاضعه لسيطره
الاحتلال التركي وهم ايضا يتواجد امراء
هناك في هذه المناطق يوجد ايضا نشاط كبير
وايضا تنفيذ لعمليات التحالف في المناطق
الخاضعه على سيطره الاحتلال التركي همم
قتل اكثر من من امير من من تنظيم داعش ضمن
مناطق سيطره الاحتلال التركي من الرقه
العميد علي الحسن للاداره العامه لقوى
الامن الداخلي التابع للاداره الذاتيه
الكرديه بسوريا شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
قال النائب العام الايراني محمد جعفر
منتظري بعد مضيء اكثر من 100 يوم على
اندلاع الاحتجاجات في ايران قال ان رد
النهائي على شكوى عائله الفتاه الكرديه
مهسا امين التي قتلت في سبتمبر الماضي لم
يعلن حتى الان منتظر اضاف ان الطب الشرعي
اعلن عن الاراء التخصصيه الشامله والكامله
في القضيه الا ان اسره امين قدمت شكوى ضد
المجلس الطبي
واشار منتظري الى ان شكوى عائله امينه تمت
احالتها الى الهيئه الطبيه للحصول على
الخبره ولم يعلن الخبراء المجلس الطبي في
المجلس الطبي رايهم النهائي بعد وكانت
هيئه الطب الشرعيه زعمت في تقريرها بان
سبب وفاه امينه لم يكن نتيجه تعرضها للضرب
لعوامل اساسيه سابقه في ما يؤكد والد ماسه
بانه راى بام عينه اثار دمنه وكدمات على
جسد ابنته
دوليا دعا المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه النجف برايس الى الافراجي غير
المشروط عن جميع من تم سجنهم في ايران
بسبب ممارسه حرياتهم بشكل سلمي حسب تعبيره
برايس اشرف في تغريده على تويتر الى
مسانده واشنطن لنساء ايران بعد طرد طهران
من لجنه المراه في الامم المتحده في وقت
سابق هذا الشهر واضاف ان الكفاح من اجل
حصوله نساء ايران على حقوقهن مستمر وفقا
ما كتبه في التغريده
التاسع مستمره وفيها ولكن بعد قليل
ان قرات استدعي السفير الفرنسي وتبلغه عدم
الارتياح مما وصفتها بالدعايه الكرديه بعد
هجوم باريس
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا الى التاسعه يرتفع التوتر
بين الصين والتايوان حيث تواصل بكين
انشطتها العسكريه بالقرب من الجزيره التي
تعتبرها جزء من اراضيها بينما تعيش تايوان
في ظل تهديد مستمر باشتياحها من قبل الصين
اخر التهديدات كان اجراء الصين لمناورات
ضمت احدى وسبعين طائره حربيه وسبع سفن
باتجاه تايوان خلال اخر 24 ساعه
[موسيقى]
اخذت التوترات وبين الصين وتايوان منحا
جديدا مع ابلاغ الاخيره عن مناورات عسكريه
اجرتها بكين نهايه الاسبوع وصفت بالاكبر
حتى لحظه الدفاع التايوانيه قالت ان الجيش
الصيني ارسل اكثر من 70 طائره مقاتله وسبع
سفن باتجاه تايوان من بينها 47 طائره عبرت
خط المنتصف بمضيق تايوان وهو حدود غير
رسميه قبلها الجانبان ضنيا من بين
الطائرات التي ارسلتها الصين نحو تايوان
18 طائره مقاتله من طراز جي 16 و11 مقاتله
من طراز جي 1 وست مقاتلات من طراز سو 30
التي تعد الاكثر تقدما اعزت الصين
تدريباتها العسكريه الاخيره التي ركزت على
توجيه ضربات في البحر والمجال الجوي قرب
تايوان الى ما وصفته باستفزازات والولايات
المتحده لم تخفي الصين قها من تنام
التعاون العسكري بين واشنطن وتيبي حيث
انتقدت مشروع قانون الانفاق الدفاعي
الامريكيه السنوي والذي يعتمدته اداره جو
بايدن باعتباره استفزازا سياسيا وكثفت
الصين من مناوراتها الحربيه حول تايوان
منذ اغسط الماضي في اعقابي زياره اثاره
الكثير من الجدل قامت بها رئيسه مجلس
النواب الامريكي نانسي بوليسي حيث تنظر
الصين الى زيارات الحكومات الاجنبيه
التيوان على انها اعتراف فعليا بالجزيره
وتحدي لمطالبتها بالسياده عليها رشا خياط
العربيه
[موسيقى]
الى ميلاد كورونا هل على العالم ان يجهز
كماماته مره اخرى سؤال يدور في بالي منظمه
الصحه العالميه حاليا في الصينيون ليسوا
وحدهم يعيشون حاله خوف بسبب العوده الشرسه
لفايروس كورونا وانما العالم اجمع دول
كثيره على راسها الهند في اسيا والمانيا
في اوروبا وغيرها بدات بالفعل باتخادي
اجراءات احترازي يتحسبا لموجه جديده تمتد
من الصين التي خرج منها اول مصاب بالفيروس
قبل حوالي ثلاثه اعوام السلطات في الصين
دافعت بالفرق الطبيه لزياره المنازل
وتقديم مبالغ ماليه للمسنين الذين تجاوزت
اعمارهم 60 عاما وذلك مقابل الموافقه على
تناول لقاح كرونه وبينما تحاول الصين لذلك
مناعه تزايد عدد الاصابات بالفيروس يسود
القلق وسط المسنين اذا الحمى والجلطات
الدمويه والاثار الجانبيه الاخرى التي قد
ترافق الاصابه بالفايروس الاصابات في
الصين ضعفت المخاوف حول العالم مسيما وانه
في ظل هذه الاصابات بكرونا ستكون هناك
ملايين الطفرات وبالتالي قد تكون واحده
منها على الاقل ذات تاثير من ناحيه العدوى
الشديده او سرعه الانتقال لذلك فان الوضع
في الصين مرشح لانتاج طفارات خطيره من
الفايروس
عندما ناكل بالخارج لكن لا يزال الناس
بحاجه الى الاعتناء بانفسهم وارتداء
الكمامات حتى لو كانت نتيجه الفحص الطبي
ايجابيه
الاصابه بالعدوى مره ثانيه فمن الممكن ان
تصاب بالعدوى اكثر من مره طويل
المزيد ينضم الينا عبر سكايب من اكسفورد
دكتور احمد سلمان استاذ علم المناعه
وتطوير اللقاحات في معهد ادوارد جينر
وزبير كليه كيلد في جامعه اكسفورد اهلا بك
دكتور اسمح لي ان ابدا بسؤال اساسي هل
هناك من تفسير لماذا استقرت كورونا في
الصين
اداره الازمه في الصين خلال الفتره
الماضيه لم تكن موفقه ولم تكن الافضل
الاغلاقات او زيرو كوفي اللي كانت بتتبعها
الصين لم تكن الافضل ولن تكون مجديه ولن
تكون مجديه مع بيروس تنفسي سريع في
الانتشار ولابد من بناء مناعه مجتمعيه ضده
عن طريق الانفتاح تدريجيا وبناء المناعه
المجتمعيه
اكيد اكيد اللقاحات فعاله ولها دور كبير
جدا ولكن مهم ايضا ان يتم بناء المناعه
سواء ضد الكرونه او الفيروسات التنفسيه
الاخرى يعني هناك الكثير من فيروسات البرد
موجوده خلال هذه الفتره سواء في اوروبا او
امريكا ليست كورونا وليست انفلونزا ولكن
نتيجه الاغلاقات سواء في مثلا الاطفال
الذين لم يتعرضوا لها خلال الفتره الماضيه
يعني سريعه الانتشار وايضا تحدث يعني
العديد من الاصابات والضغط على الانظمه
الصحيه وبالتالي التعامل مع الفيروسات
التنفسيه بصوره عامه عن طريق الاغلاقات
يعني ليست الافضل ومكرون ظهر في نهايه
العام الماضي تقريبا في ديسمبر 20 21 يعني
حوالي عام من الان وطهر همم وان وتو و3 و4
و5 والان عندنا بي اف همم 7 وهناك طبعا
المتغيرات الاخرى وبالتالي الناس كانت
بتتعرض لهذه المتغيرات الاضعاف كثيرا من
المتغير الموجود حتى الان او يعني الذي
ضاع الان هو بي اف 7 وبالتالي تدريجيا امم
تتكون عندنا مناعه مجتمعيه بالاضافه
دكتور احمد
لابد من اخذ الحظر ولكن لا داعي للدار او
الخوف بصوره مبالغ فيها للاسف الاحصائيات
الصادره من الصين هي تبدو مرعبه لانه كما
ذكرت اا لم يتم بناء مناعه مجتمعيه كان
هناك ضعف كبير جدا في الاقبال على
اللقاحات خصوصا من الفئه الاكثر عرضه يعني
الاحصائيات بتقول انه من هم فوق ال 65 عام
هم اقل اقبالا في الصين على تلقي اللقاحات
وهي للاسف الفئه اكثر عرضه للاصابه
وبالتالي لذلك همم
احصائيات التي ظهرت حتى الان بتشرى لانه
همم المتغير به اف 7 همم الار فاكتور او
نسبه العدو في تقريبا من 10 اشخاص ل 18
وسته من 10 شخص وده يعني نسبه مرتفع جدا
ولكن يرجع جزء منها نتيجه عدم وجود مناعه
ضد تغيرت ميكرود بصوره عامه في بلد زي
الصوم
فيها نحن نتخوف من ان تكون اقصى الان او
انه فقط سرعه الانتشار
حتى الان همم لا يوجد ما يشير على انه ال
ال الاصابه او شراسه العدوى اسوا من
سلالات الميكرون الاخرى ولكن الذي تم
تاكيده هي سرعه الانتشار وكما ذكرت يعزى
جزء كبير من ذلك يعني التفسير او
الاحصائيات نتيجه عدم وجود المناعه وطبعا
همم كما ذكرت يعني عدم الاقبال على
اللقاحات بسرعه عامه في الصين وايضا
اللقاح الصيني بالرغم من انه اللقاح فعال
ولكن واقل اللقاحات تقريبا التي ظهرت خلال
الفتره الماضيه في الفعاليه وفي طول فتره
المناعه وبالتالي كل ده جعل احصائيات
الصادره من الصين اكثر يعني همم مبالغ
فيها بصوره كبيره جدا ولكن حتى يعني لا
نثير همم الرعب مهم جدا الالتزام بالطرق
الوقائيه بقدر المستطاع الكمامه تلقي
اللقاحات التعزيزيه وطبعا التعامل معك اي
من سلالات الاخرى او المتقادات الاخرى من
همم كورولا وان شاء الله يعني لن يكون
هناك ما يثير الرعب والفساد
الفردوس استاذ علم المناعه وتطوير
اللقاحات في معهد ادوارد جينر وزميل كليات
كلوك في جامعه اكسفورد شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
بعد وقت قصير على انطلاقها انهت الشرطه
الفرنسيه تظاهرا للجاليه الكرديه في باريس
سانديدا باعتداء الدائره العاشره والذي
اودى بحياه ثلاثه اكراد مراسل العربيه
افاد بانتهاء التظاهره تجنبا لاعمال شغب
وسط انتشار امن كثيف في وسط العاصمه اضاف
مراسل العربيه ان النيابه العامه الفرنسيه
طلبت حبسه منفذ الهجوم على المركز الكردي
بباريس مؤقتا ياتي ذلك في ما مثل المتهم
في اعتداء باريس امام قاده التحقيق حيث
اقر بانه يشعر بكراهيه بمرضيه حيل الاجانب
واضاف انه يشعر بالدم لانه لم يقتل عددا
اكبر من الاكراد
وفي ظل اتهامات من اطراف كرديه بوقوف خليه
تابعه لتركيا وراء الهجوم استدعت انقره
قبل حوالي الساعه السفير الفرنسي بدريعه
الترويج للدعايه معاديه لتركيا بعد اعتداء
باريس وقد المحدث باسم المجلس الديمقراطي
الكردي في فرنسا بان تركيا تقف وراء مقتل
الاكرادات نتابع
رايت المركبه التركيه شخصيا ولدينا صورها
وهي تدخل ساحه الجمهوريه وعليها علامه
ذئاب الرماديه تابعه للحركه القوميه
المتطرفه وهي طريقه استفزازيه اشعلت غضب
الناس الذين تجمعوا في الساحه حاولنا
التدخل بين المتظاهرين والشرطه ولم ننجح
للاسف مضطرنا الى الغاء التظاهر
[موسيقى]
واجه البريطانيون مشاكل في التنقل بسبب
اضراب عمال سكك الحديد في يوم اعتدى فيه
المتفوقون اقتناء عروض مغريه في اكبر
تنزيلات تشهدها البلاد وشاهدت المراكز
التجاريه التي توفر مواقف للسيارات اقبالا
كبيرا عليها وفي شوارع التسوق بوسط لندن
التي لم تتاثر كثيرا بالمدربين في قطاع
القطارات متابعه
هو اكثر الايام روجا يوم يعول عليه قطاع
التجزئه لانجاز اكبر قدر ممكن من المبيعات
بعد تخفيض البضائع الى نصف سعرها او حتى
اكثر فرصه للمتسوقين لشراء ما يحتاجون
باقل كلفه لكنه موارده الماليه تحت ضغط
كبير في خضم اسوء غلاء معيشه تشهد البلاد
من ما يحد من قدراتهم الشرائيه
المعيشه تاثير على انفاق الجميع بقله
مواردهم الماليه
[موسيقى]
في هذا اليوم الذي يعرف بيوم الصناديق او
بوكس
مليار جنيه مقارنه بالعام الماضي بحسب
مركزي هات البيع بالتجزئه ازمه تكلفه
المعيشه من جهه واضراب عمال سكك الحديد من
جهه ثانيه وراء انخفاض مبيعات في موسم
جنون التسوق هذا
نقابه المضربين في قطاع السكك الحديد تدرك
مدى الاضطرابات التي خلفها وقف القطارات
في ايجاد وسيله اخرى لتنقل الركاب وتصر
على المضيء في اضرابها الى ان تستجيب
الحكومه لمطالبها برفع الاجور وحمايه
الوظائف
ادعموا المضربين حتى تدرك الحكومه ان
سائقي القطارات واخرين في سكك الحديد
يحتاجون الى مزيد من المال لمواجهه الغلاء
اكثر بقليل
اربعه مليار جنيه في هذا اليوم سينجز عبر
الانترنت لتوفير الوقت والمالي وتعب
التنقل وما تطمح اليه المحال التجاريه
بتقديم عروض مغريه لجذب المتسوقين اليها
لن تحققه في ظل نسبه تضخم تتجاوز عشره في
المئه زادت من ارتفاع المعيشه دون رفع
الاجور يتماشى مع التحديات الاقتصاديه
مصطفى زارو العربيه
ظاهره جديده في كره القدم وهي تغطيه
اللاعبين لافواههم عند الحديث عن ارضيه
الملعب فما هو السبب
[موسيقى]
هذه وقفه مع ابرز احداث اليوم لهذا العام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
يعني
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ستكون مملكه بدورها في هذا المجال حيث ان
اعلنت عن زياده مستوى طاقتها الانتاجيه
الى 13 مليون برميل يوميا وبعد ذلك لن
يكون لدى المملكه اي قدره اضافيه لزياده
الانتاج وندعوران باعتبارها دوله جاره
يربطنا بشعبها روابط دينيه وثقافيه الى
التعاون مع دول منطقه لتكون جزء من هذه
الرؤيا والتعاون مع وكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه والوفاء في هذا الشهر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ماهر المانيا
[موسيقى]
الالف
منظمه دوليه خامسه تعلق عملها بافغانستان
بعد تمسك طالبان بقرار حظر النساء من
العمل
سفاره السعوديه في باكستان تدعون مواطنيها
لتوخي الحذر بعد رفع حاله التاهب في اسلام
اباد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وفي سوريا ثمانيه قتلى بهجوم لداعش على
سجن بالرقه والتحالف يكشف عملياته ضد
تنظيم
مشاهدينا تاسع انتهت ولكن الاخبار مستمره
مع طاهر و360 طاهر
بالمزيد من التفصيل اضافه الى حديثنا مع
احدى الطالبات الجامعيات الافغانيات من
اللائي حرمنا مؤخرا من قبل طالبه من
التوجه الى الجامعه
ان شاء الله